[Musique]
la 36e édition des journées européennes
du patrimoine s'est déroulé ces 21 et 22
septembre autour du thème européen arts
et divertissements comme chaque année le
département à proposer des visites
gratuites de ces sites culturels comme
au musée historique de villèle plusieurs
activités autour de ce domaine on vous
raconte même l'histoire de cette famille
beaucoup de g l'otan des devinettes à la
créole on nous fait découvrir l'histoire
de cette famille l'histoire de ce
domaine
l'espagne va quand même participer aussi
au fonctionnement de la réunion et va
même faire évoluer la réunion avec les
industries de sucrière autour de la
réunion et vont participer à l'évolution
de la réunion tout au long du week-end
concerts et animations ont été proposées
au public ainsi que des jeux pour les
enfants afin de découvrir l'histoire de
la réunion de façon ludique
alors le jeu de piste familial permet
aux familles de découvrir les différents
bâtiments du site tout en s'amusant
c'est à dire que ils vont aller à
différents devant les différents
bâtiments
ils vont lire les totems ou les bornes
s'ils n'ont pas l'information sur ces
éléments il pose des questions aux
guides ils remplissent leurs carnets au
bout de 45 minutes
ils reviennent donc au stand et on
procède à la correction il n'y a pas de
perdant bien sûr parce que tout le monde
est censé gagner puisque et surtout
l'intéressée d'apprendre des choses sur
l'histoire la réunion sur l'histoire du
domaine il soit la réunion en fait on
utilisait nous tuer on sait tout cela
fait que ça aura un espace y ont fait de
pascal écoles y apprennent pas nous tous
on y apprend dans l'histoire en deux ans
et york en panne ou l'histoire d'aregno
fait b mais vous y apprendrez nous
l'histoire la réunion la promotion 19 de
l' académie des dalons structures du
département pour adolescents et jeunes
adultes qui favorise l'insertion sociale
et professionnelle a également proposé
un spectacle c'est un travail collectif
autour de l'identité puis surtout pour
eux pour les jeunes un dépassement de
soi joue un peu devant tout le monde
c'était voilà se dépasser puis
travailler un petit peu l'expression et
puis sont réaffirmées un peu que ça nous
les gentils être mélangés que nous en
sert tout ça ben ali pendant onze ans
longtemps mon règne maloya refont le
caire tout ça super super à oui c'est
super
en tout cas on connaît qu'on à mettre le
feu à une 36ème édition des journées
européennes du patrimoine réussi cette
année encore les visiteurs sont venus
nombreux
[Musique]